how much you think uh voter fraud is
going to take
uh into account meaning you think
there's going to be a lot of voter fraud
there's going to be there is already has
been voters automatically
you think they're going to get caught do
you think there's going to be you know
where it's going to be lawsuits and
there might be what president do we have
i've heard a video prepared a video
what history do we have of anybody being
a sore loser ever
besides what history do we have of ever
having a president like trump oh
i mean talk about sora losing here watch
this 24 second video watch his 24 by the
way it's got 7.8 million views in less
than 24 hours
we're in a situation where we have put
together
and you guys did it for our administ the
president obama's administration
before this we have put together i think
the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
secondly uh
well what do you think he meant by that
what do you legitimately don't be don't
don't be political here go go back
yes he says some ridiculous [ __ ] go back
from 12 seconds
go press play we have put together
i think the most extensive
and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
second so first of all what mark is
saying like you know you gotta
pick and choose your words what you're
saying a guy running for office and we
put together the greatest
voter you know organization voter fraud
organization
what is he saying now he probably meant
to say and this is welcome to joe
biden's world fraud prevention uh
fraud prevention election protection go
ahead protect him
okay so do you actually think he came
out there says guys we did it we're
gonna
full-on we got the voter fraud committee
where it's going down
it's happening on tuesday the media
doesn't seem to seriously you know
what do you think he meant byron be
apolitical for one second i think he
probably meant to say the opposite
okay pat what do you think be apolitical
for a second
you could still make fun of joe and call
him a crazy dementia sleepy joke but
what do you actually think he meant i
i actually think you know here's a
problem i'll tell you what the problem
is
when hillary was running hillary thought
100 percent she's gonna win right she
acted like she was a president two years
before she even
was you know queen hillary she was like
it was no question i don't even need to
campaign i'm gonna be the president
because
every single media is on my side
everybody's on my side there's no way in
the world i'm going to lose this right
obama wasn't like that obama was
fighting obama was paranoid right you
know you know how biden talks right now
biden talks as if he's already the
president biden talks as if he can get
away with anything
biden for 47 years has been able to get
all these if any of these laptop deals
with tony guy coming out
if any of this stuff is true for 47
years this guy's been doing deals and
getting away with it
you have to realize it gets to a point
where in the mob if you're untouchable
they call you untouchable you don't
think you can be touched so you say
and you you feel you can get up there
and say anything
nothing's going to happen to you
nothing's going to happen to you when
you have that kind of a mindset you
don't really care what you're going to
say so i don't know what he means by
this
could he be said voter prevention fraud
prevention
maybe that's what he's talking about is
he trying to say we have the best
for a voter fraud team put together
maybe that's what he's talking about you
actually think that's what he meant
i don't know what he's talking about
because i don't think he has a good
filtering system okay you know right
before you're about to say something
so how do i look well you kind of look
fat you know
and then people who have comments since
they're like first answer comes up you
kind of look fat
you look great you know you're not good
you know it's a all right so how do you
do i have a big this makes my butt look
big
yes you got a fat ass girl no yeah i
know you look great right
right so what do i do you know how do i
do you know in our business when people
go give up
give a speech and they get off the stage
and they say so how do i do
you're like shittiest time i've heard of
my life and then you say
dude you did good man good stuff yeah
yeah yeah awesome thanks
so i don't think he was gifted with that
filter
yeah okay if that makes any sense
joe's had his foot in his mouth for 40
seconds i think he has it let me respond
to that
let me respond to that number one you're
absolutely right that obama had to work
his ass off
because he didn't have the entitlement
issue he came out of nowhere
excuse me what is that it's a plan it's
important oh gotcha didn't i have the
intel what are you talking about
meaning he didn't come from the uh 47
years in politics he didn't come from
one
dynasty he didn't come from the clinton
the minute dynasty made his speech in
2004 they knew they were going to try to
make him president
he was anointed okay anointed sure media
fell in love with him
okay granted he still had to win though
he still had to work his ass off he
wasn't like i am king obama
he still had to go through he had to go
through the campaign
yes he had to campaign his ass off he
was not anointed he had to work his ass
off okay
hillary clinton on the other hand
totally agree with pat
she was the first lady senator you know
she was waiting for her coronation
exactly secretary of state she's running
against this
fool as she called him billboard said
she looks like a real estate agent i
don't trust her
you know so granted
that's clearly now with biden i don't
think he has
the confidence by any stretch to think
that he's going to be anointed
but whether you love buying or hate bite
and i don't know a lot of people that
love him i think there's a lot of people
that don't like trump
the one thing that him and trump have in
common and this is
this is true to trump for sure and for
some reason true for biden
is they are teflon not a lot of things
stick like after the grabbing by the
[ __ ] thing
and trump became the president clearly
they're like you know what
we're good with it it's okay the racism
stuff the uh the spazzing out thing the
mexicans are rapists people are like you
know what
but it never goes away the media trump
is running against biden campaign and
he's running against the media the media
is there
protecting and supporting biden every
step of the way you know that
80-90 of the media journalists what have
you
95 vote democrat sure granted
but what we can establish is donald
trump does have a teflon quality about
him yeah yeah
yeah somewhat nothing like bill clinton
had bill that's the best
but even joe even sleepy joe crazy joe
whatever you want to call him
dementia joe has some sort of teflon or
he this would have been a blowout race
already that's some kind of thing
yeah the teflon is the media so okay a
question for you you're so funny did you
actually say
biden's got the teflon let me ask you a
question because we're going to revisit
this in one week if biden happens to win
this rake
race somehow somehow will you at least
be willing to admit that he's got a
teflon quality about it
i wouldn't give you you will not give
him that even if he wins even if he wins
he has teflon quality even if he wins
pat
wait he has teflon quality if he wins
clearly
he's got something have to do with
teflon what what does
winning have to do with tough if if if
trump lost would would be calling him
teflon don
no no what i'm trying exactly you got to
win in order to beat that
it's got nothing to do with teflon who
was the original teflon don it's got to
do with uh
gotti yeah okay because nothing could
ever stick to the guy
right so what's your favorite the same
thing with trump no biden is not the one
biden's not a tough biden doesn't
qualify to be in the toughest if you win
the presidency how could you not say
that
biden qualifies biden qualifies
for absolute perfect timing to be a
candidate that could potentially be a
president
in no other lifetime would this guy have
had a chance to be a president except
today
because of coronavirus because of what's
going on with the pandemic because of
how that was used to shut down so many
different states and show varieties and
show protesting
to show americans and havoc you know
problems everywhere it's all because of
trump it's all because of trump it's all
because of trump
if you notice during obama we didn't
have rights like this we didn't have
rights like this
well most of the writers are on which
side on the left side so they're going
against trump
rights don't riot the way left right
left's right a whole different way than
rights right
so if you go breaking that part down he
got pres if he was president
it's because of timing he's got nothing
to do with him and the media is
cooperating
okay i do agree with you on timing
however if this were
bernie sanders running against trump
right now do you think bernie would be
ahead in the polls do you think
bernie would have a better chance than
biden speaking of timing i think
biden do you think elizabeth warren so
you're saying
you're saying whoever would run would
get warren okay
but bernie would have a better chance i
think bernie and pete as well by the way
pete to me is
you think pete could have beat trump i
think i think i think
pete to me is a better
on tv candidate debate poise
going back and forth being able to have
that fight i think peter's ten times
better than biden in that area no no
no doubt resumes way smarter no doubt
they're not in the same league
do you understand and again this this
might cause ruffle some feathers all you
have to do is put a picture
and you know trump would do this so i'm
saying what all you have to do is
picture of him and melania
first lady and pete and chasden
that's your first lady take your pick
guys you don't think he would throw that
out there into the atmosphere
of course take your pick yeah done
pete's done
i'm just i don't know man
no the whole pablo the whole uh
diversity thing
is something the country i mean obama
got elected the first time
largely because a huge swath of the
country
wanted to prove that they weren't racist
there's no question he
no chance he could have gotten elected
if he wasn't black not a chance in a
million not with that resume
not a chance he had what had he done he
had done nothing
absolutely nothing so you need to have a
immaculate resume
decent resume you have to have done
something never do
the government it was the governor okay
governor obama so obama was a senator is
that much of a major difference 20
minutes for 20 minutes
he started running for president wait
wait wait wait please answer the
question for him
is there a major difference between
being a senator and a governor huge
difference tell them tell them police
understand the difference senators don't
do anything they just show up maybe they
vote yes or no they don't
can't believe you said they don't have
to do anything governors are running
things they're actually running
they're running a state they're running
a government they're doing something and
in fact
there hadn't been a senator elected
since kennedy okay i mean it's always a
governor someone who's actually done
something and run something with a
proven track record of of
having its staff and having having a
payroll and having to be responsible for
a budget senators are responsible for
almost nothing
who's the first person you voted for
jimmy carter was jimmy carter a governor
yes he was he
was governor of georgia yes sir okay all
right
so i stand corrected
i'm willing to admit i'm willing to
admit
who reagan was a governor yes was george
h.w bush a governor
yes he was yes okay was bill clinton the
governor yes yes
arkansas was obama a governor no no one
term senator exactly one
thing and he had never sponsored that's
my point guys he had never written me a
sentence
never written or sponsored any
legislation when he was in illinois he
voted present like 400 and something
times he didn't want to actually
he was basically setting the table for
this the whole time so no one could say
well you voted for a bill that said this
that or the other because all these
bills are never clean
they're never like hey it's just one
issue bill there's a bill from chicago
though so you've been watching obama for
years
you know what's going on with this guy
there's nobody more teflon than that guy
okay are you obama fan or no no you're
not obama fan
no never liked him i always thought he
was fraudulent
his true idea fraudulent yes true
ideology he tried to hide it it came out
a few times with joe the plumber and a
few other things
you didn't build that and you know cling
to your guns and religion and all that
when he was on when he thought he was
unplugged it came out but by and large
he was able to hide it
what do you think make himself look
centrist what do you think was
fraudulent
he did he didn't disclose his true
ideology
what was that communism
you think he's a communist communist
socialism yes that's what he that's he
wanted to fundamentally transform our
country
when by and large most of the country
did not want to be fundamentally
transformed
and whatever we wanted to make a
statement communist what evidence we
have
if you watch the movie uh 2016 obama's
america
have you seen them watch the movie and
then i just i'd rather take the cliff
notes
what evidence do we have that there's
how about he was a communist party about
his book
in his own words the communist manifesto
what was it no not that but about his
father
yeah yeah dreams of my father okay he
narrated it in his own voice and
i'm looking at eight years of presidency
what do we have that's
well he didn't govern that he didn't
govern that way because he was afraid to
he didn't think he could get it passed
and he was afraid to get through so i'm
going on
him being a president for eight years i
didn't look at him and be like there's
my communist president
if he if he had governed that way in the
first four years he would never have
been elected
okay in the second four years he didn't
have control of the house and the senate
like he did in the first four years the
first two years first two years
he's speculating that he was there's no
question he he was pragmatic about how
he was going to advance his agenda he
did as much as he thought he could
communism obama do you agree with byron
well i mean his father was a communist
his stepfather or the guy that his wife
his mother put in to be is just because
it's just because your
family like but but he was very open
that his mom was a
but he writes a book about he was trying
to live life so in the dreams of his
father i mean he there's no question
that he
when i was in college i hung out with
all the radicals blah blah i mean
everything he said everything he did
i mean he he hung out in a church with
reverend wright for years and years and
years who was his mentor who married him
this guy is known for saying god damn
america and obama's like oh i didn't
know he said stuff like that i mean just
complete
talk about tough the media never took
him to texas
i do put about socialists and i do put
about him not loving america
of what america was founded on he may
have loved the america that he wanted to
turn america into
i agree but i don't know about communist
i would say socialist
yes and i would say he didn't love the
america on the
foundations it was founded on but why
don't we go put anita
anita young on his cabinet anita is
anita young is that her name
i need a done i need it done this woman
was
her they asked her who her idols were
she said i have two idols in the world
mother teresa and mouzy tongue this is a
woman that he put on his cabinet
he put on that guy vince whatever the
guy that jones van jones van jones this
guy was a card-carrying community
much of it i mean he was these were two
people in his cabinet week or two he was
like gone
i'm just saying he put two people that
were known communist
you know ideologues on his cabinet i
mean how do you do that you don't know
that that's what they are
do you watch van jones on cnn yeah do
you appreciate his opinion i like van
jones he's come around a little bit i
like that
i i actually find him to be highly
credible when
in 2016 when when trump won he was
actually one of the first people to come
out and say look guys
we didn't get it i wasn't a i you know
we called this wrong
i'm willing to admit he's my president
like i respect his opinion do i
agree with his opinion all the time i
think he's i think he's a very smart
talented guy no i
again i give you my positions on obama
on how i viewed obama
it's very simple how i view who he was
and what he did
very simple on who he was and what he
[Music]
did